star of my show tell them who you are
I'm captain
you need to think about what other
people think of your army if somebody
says that you're dumb you say okay okay
[Music]
you're the smartest girl here give me a
hug thank you good she knows what's your
problem and I said that if
somebody says that I'm dumb whatever
okay tell them I don't care we don't
care about your hate we don't care I
have a song and I have a um dance I made
up called the sloth and it goes like
this and one time at school somebody
told me that the dance was Dumb and I'm
like I don't care if it's dumb I don't
care we can't hear you yeah I love the
dance I love the swap it's all about the
sloth I mean some sloth I don't care if
somebody doesn't like it slaw